dramatische szenen in der new yorker
u-bahn am dienstagmorgen 8 uhr 30
ortszeit fallen in einem bahnhof schüsse
13 menschen sollen verletzt worden sein
die feuerwehr berichtet von rauch der an
der 36 straße im stadtteil brooklyn
aufsteigt mehrere verdächtige
gegenstände wurden gefunden ein new
yorker bombenentschärfungskommando ist
laut medienberichten im einsatz während
feuerwehr und polizei den tatort
untersuchen tauchen erste bilder und
videos im internet auf zu sehen sind
blutüberströmte menschen und weißer
rauch in der u bahn station
nach dem täter wird medienberichten
zufolge noch gesucht
kam es zu diesem zwischenfall das war
genau natürlich in der rushhour es gibt
verschiedene informationen die sich
zusammenfügen zu einem doch
erschreckenden bild wie gesagt es gibt
berichte jetzt von insgesamt 13
verletzten bereits und man hat auch auf
social media wirklich wahre horror
bilder gesehen von menschen die
bahnsteige gelegen sind am boden
geblutet menschen die am telefon war
menschen die ihnen geholfen haben die
gliedmaßen abgebunden haben all das
jemand auf social media rund um die
diese suppe station in sunset park in
brooklyn wir wurde jetzt natürlich alles
abgesperrt es ist ein gewaltiges
aufgebot aller sicherheitskräfte polizei
feuerwehr und rettungsfahrzeuge
natürlich der der tatort oder dieser
schreckens ort ist bereits weitflächig
abgesperrt worden es kommen jetzt immer
mehr schaulustige aber auch reporter und
auch immer mehr ordnungshüter hierher
und die frage natürlich die sich alle
new yorker jetzt stellen was ist hier
passiert ist das gar einen
terroranschlag
natürlich die die verschiedenen elemente
dieser dieses vorfalls sind sehr
beunruhigend wie gesagt die rechte von
rauch am bahnsteig das deutet darauf hin
dass es möglicherweise eine explosion
gegeben habe berichtete von schüssen von
verletzten die rechte eines flüchtenden
täters der möge sogar eine gasmaske
tragen hat all das deutet jedoch hin auf
einen gezielten anschlag wer nicht auf
einen terroranschlag und das ist
natürlich in new york immer ein
absolutes schreckensszenario die stadt
die eben immer noch das trauma erleidet
nach den terroranschlägen des 11
september bei den nun heißt es in der
amerikanischen version 5 people a shot
also sie sind getroffen worden reden wir
hier auch von fünf toten
das würde heißen dass sie angeschossen
worden es gibt noch keine detaillierten
zahlen über mögliche tote
das wird man jetzt in den nächsten
minuten an stunden wahrscheinlich
erfahren aber es deutet doch daraufhin
aufgrund der bilder und der
eskalierenden nachrichtenlage das hier
doch etwas ganz schreckliches passiert
sein muss in diesen zügen oder vor den
zügen oder in bahnsteig wo rund um diese
linie die durch brooklyn führt und
rockland mit manhattan verbindet und man
darf annehmen dass hier viele menschen
unterwegs fanden new york ist eigentlich
fast zufällig zur normalität
zurückgekehrt das heißt die u bahnen
sind wieder randvoll im pendlerverkehr
besonders in der morning rush hour und
so gesehen ist es wirklich ein absolutes
horrorszenario